I'm gonna say this right now at the
start the video this is one of the very
best books I've ever read now if that's
not a good start to a book review I
don't know what is hello and welcome to
the Simon Oxford's book club if you are
new here this is the series of videos
where we me and you the audience all
read a book together and then we talk
about it in addition to the discussion
that happens in the comment sections in
these videos there is also a Goodreads
group for the book club which I'll put a
link to down there same place of the
comments below me but you know it's in
the description it was on the Goodreads
group where we picked by poll sapiens a
brief history of humankind about you've
all know her re as a book to read and
holy cow it's amazing reading this book
felt like I'd lived in a landscape all
my life and then suddenly one day I was
invited to climb a really really tall
tower and I got to the top and I could
see all the roads and the connections
between the towns that I never even knew
existed before everything was laid out
in a way that was simultaneously
enlightening dizzying and kind of
disorienting one trying to say is that
this book deals with big big themes
themes that will affect everybody who
has read it like religion the economy
why humans are here and make connections
between subject areas that are not
immediately obvious least they weren't
to me and really changes your perception
about some big big things in life on the
Goodreads it was actually accurately I
think described as the book that you
give to an alien if they could read
perfect English to help them understand
humans and what makes us us and all the
big big parks of societies like I said
the economy religion why we are here is
a species of humans and not some other
species like Homo habilis and I'll be
honest I went to this book really really
interested in the early stuff I've
always had a fascination with human
prehistory and I'm our evolutionary
history Out of Africa into homo sapiens
sapiens and that was the hook for this
book and I remember reading this in a
park and thinking wow this is amazing
stuff this is just great I don't want
this section to end and then after that
section it got on to the Agricultural
Revolution and I didn't want it to end
and at the Agricultural Revolution it
went on to all the other revolutions in
history like the Scientific Revolution
and the dust revolution and I never
wanted it to finish it was very
much like zen and the art of motorcycle
maintenance which is a very very high
praise coming from you that's one of my
favorite books of all time as now is
this I'd like to point out in the I got
about the last hundred pages and this
was at about I think twelve or one at
night I just kept reading I just didn't
want to put it down I had to get to the
end even though it's nonfiction it it
almost reads like a thriller so you can
probably tell I'm a little bit enthused
about this book like I think you should
read this to take a step back I so if
you can make this out so the books
divided into different revolutions at
the top you've got the cognitive
revolution and then after that you've
got what the agricultural unification of
humankind scientific and those are like
the four main sections and then within
those there are other evolutions like
you know the Industrial Revolution for
example and it's very interesting in
that Harare approaches the book which is
basically all the humanities all the
humanities like in a very very broad
sense of covered in this book he
approaches the humanities as a scientist
would which is interesting he's got a
PhD in history from Oxford he approaches
it in very kind of cold distant language
not to say the prose isn't could the
prose is brilliant it's like Mary beard
I think it's of a comparable level to
Mary beards prose and that it's very
crisp fantastic - metaphor no language
is used it's more complicated than it
needs to be but it still reads
fantastically well the approach is kind
of cold and so it establishes humans as
something that is totally unremarkable
we are just like every other animal and
talks about the fact that it was a
competition between species for Homo
sapiens to even emerge as the dominant
and only now in fact human species on
earth but then having built up humans
has been completely unexceptional he
then shows how in everywhere humans are
completely different from other animals
again in the same kind of distant tone
the scientist would take by talking
about the invention of mythologies the
idea to imagine things that do not
really exist in the world and just the
idea of something that comes in early on
I was always going to say it's a spoiler
again I feel like I'm spoiling a
thriller something that comes in early
on is the idea of treating something
like a history or a culture or a
religion as a series of myths
in that they are things that don't
really exist me as the concept of me
being for example British isn't there's
nothing physically about me that is
British because British is a completely
invented thing it's just something that
a huge number of people have
collectively agreed oh yeah that's real
that's a thing and he makes the really
interesting connection that that's
exactly the same with companies I mean I
think it's Renault that he talks about
if all the people in Renault were to be
laid off and the the company buildings
were sold and everything under the law
and in everybody's minds right I would
still exist it's a it's a collectively
agreed upon myth and it's in that vein
that he talks about money about the
relationship between capitalism and
scientific revolution there's some guns
Jen's and steel overlap here actually in
that it talks about why Europe was able
to become the colonial masters of half
the planet and the answer basically
being they were willing to admit
ignorance as part of the scientific
technique in that they were able to say
we don't know what's over there we want
to go over there and find out as opposed
to previous cultures who would say we
know what's over there it's not
important
it's it doesn't matter if they actually
knew what was over there because they
almost certainly didn't they'd say that
within our mythology it's fine it's you
know it's not a big deal why would you
want to go over there
so is that willingness to admit
ignorance combined with the capitalist
system that in I guess you call it a
hypothesis in Harare hypothesis that led
to European dominance and another
discussion that I found particularly
interesting because I'm vegetarian
there's a video about it there about why
you can be vegetarian to save the planet
as a vegetarian his discussion of the
Agricultural Revolution and the
implications for life on Earth in terms
of viewing cattle for example are some
of the most biologically successful
creatures ever to have lived because we
breed them they exist in colossal
numbers but in terms of happiness
they're some of the most miserable
creatures who have ever lived so talking
about the implications for animal
welfare and also for the environmental
considerations the second time around I
think that it talks about it of
Agriculture is incredibly interesting I
think it's a very persuasive case even
though he doesn't preach it doesn't say
what because of this you should be
vegetarian
even though he doesn't preach I think
it's a very convincing case for being
veggie personally but then again I kind
of am biased looking at the discussion
and in that discussion also of the
Agricultural Revolution the idea that
perhaps it wasn't us that domesticated
crops
it was crops he domesticated us that the
hacker culture revolution is the single
biggest hoodwink in human history and
the biggest disaster in human history in
terms of individual happiness and
comparing what the average human will
have experienced and in terms of their
happiness in terms of their day to day
lives before the Revolution and after
the Revolution and perhaps it was a
colossal mistake
but an unavoidable one as soon as one
group of humans started reaping the
rewards of Agriculture and multiplied
despite the fact that it shackled them
to the ground and to what we now you
know have modern agriculture it was
unavoidable because it's yes as soon as
one group saw the benefits every other
group had to adopt it in order to keep
pace or go extinct I'm sorry if I'm
rambling by the way but I this book I
I'm so happy that we chose this book
because if you didn't read it you should
I do have some questions people um for
those of you in the audience who did
read along what did you think of the
book first of all um I'd be interested
to know I'm not religious myself but did
his discussion of religion make sense to
you
do you did you find it offensive in any
way because it's very difficult for me
to it's obviously a very emotive subject
for people who very deeply believe it's
not something that I can comment on
really because I don't come under that
category if you aren't vegetarian what
did you make of his discussion of
Agriculture and about meat based
agriculture and then lastly if you have
any criticism at all of the book I'm
struggling I mean it but it's a long
book that's not even a criticism that's
a good thing when it's that good I'm
very finding it difficult to think of
anything negative to say about it I
really can recommend this to everybody
who decided to watch this video if you
haven't read this book absolutely should
and now for something completely
different so like I said earlier
sapiens was chosen on the goodreads by a
pole I then said that I'm just going to
pick something for us to read and I
wanted us to read something that was
fiction because nonfiction is incredibly
interesting as this book shown and you
can get great discussion out of it but I
think it'd be really interesting for us
to read a short piece of fiction and
then to share our takes on it so with
that in mind we're going to read
something really weird the next book in
the book club is going to be the
metamorphosis by Franz Kafka for those
of you who have never heard about this
this is a very short novella I think
it's actually about 100 pages long where
the protagonist wakes start of the book
to find that he's been transformed into
a giant insect like if that's not a good
opening to a book I don't know because
it's so short I'm only going to give you
a couple of weeks I think it probably
three weeks although I admittedly these
book clubs are normally a bit late I'll
give you two or three weeks to read the
book and then all there'll be another
video here and I'm going to be joined by
my housemate Dan who's actually
qualified to talk about these things
because he's an English student we're
going to have a group discussion but it
will be vastly improved by you so I'd
recommend that you should go to your
local bookshop or your local library and
get yourself a copy the next couple of
weeks
read it report back here and then down
there in the comments post what you
think also if you'd like to take an
active role in choosing what we read
together next then do join the Goodreads
group and thank you very much for
watching oh and remember to like the
video if you liked it
I'm you tuber I'm like contractually
obliged to say that thank you for
watching I'll see you in the next video